[Music]
you are choosing to be single right now
why was that a choice you made people
always ask me about my love or lack of
love life and I've been really focused
on work and my daughter so much
sometimes something has to give
if I do anything I want to do it well in
high dates I want to date really well so
I can't be dating unless I'm ready to
like go full monty cheers to that you
know and by the way that's turning now
I'm ready to get back on that horse ah I
was going to say when will you be ready
again yesterday okay yesterday so we're
out there looking I rip the band-aid off
like two days ago I did I just lit the
flame with a match but the burners on
and I'm off to the races
bethenny frankel keeping it real when it
comes to her love life after splitting
from boyfriend Dennis Shields earlier
this year
Bethany chose to focus on other projects
instead shark tank deal check housewives
going well check the market fresh deli
might new like deli lunch meat line is
amazing check so now summer is coming
it's time to put the Bethany burners
back I love it yes I go in the Hamptons
open for business also helping The Real
Housewives of New York star get back in
business
the fact that her years long divorce
from Jason Hoppy is finally over though
she still has to deal with constant
media attention surrounding their tense
relationships how do you cancel out all
the BS
sometimes it's empowering its fuel I
mean if people are really spending so
much time talking about you then you
must be doing something so right that
it's just bothering them so badly that
they have to try to say something
negative and I don't really think about
haters you know I'm happy right good
adding to all the good her new charity
be strong a partnership with Dress for
Success that helps women in crisis
it's about financial advice and life
coaching and all of that I had a rough
spot and I'm so blessed in so many ways
I couldn't believe how debilitating it
was for me so imagine people that really
don't have their electricity turned on
and you know can't pay the rent enough
to support their kids and it broke my
heart and I just felt like let me I can
do this and I'm we're doing it and we
have a charitable initiative where
people can go to raise or
and they can enter to win a trip to New
York to come spend the day with me Andy
Cohen go to watch what happens live and
and help of course women in crisis
very cool getting back yeah I'm excited
very cool thank you awesome